i also recognize that it's a passion of
mine to connect people
to israel in kind of a ver not like a
non-cynical way
[Music]
thank you so much for being on my show
how are you good thank you for having me
with a huge list of remarkable people
i'll try to drink the bar yeah
i'll try it i'll try i am extremely
excited for this
for this conversation besides the fact
that you're the founder of ezra tech
ventures which we'll of course dive into
i think talking about your journey is
extremely relevant and interesting
because like you mentioned right before
we started talking
your entrance to the tech world as an
israeli is not the
perhaps traditional you know startup
nation a
you know classic story of 8200 elite
unit whatever and then going into the
tech
yeah you had a multitude of really
fascinating positions with embassies
with diplomats
so sunny who are you and then later on
we'll dive into
a what is your tech ventures is about
yeah
well i always like to start my story in
a
town called fort worth texas
um or really christian university
yeah but beforehand i guess it all
begins
with a dramatic day that my parents told
me the worst thing that you can tell to
a 15 year old
living in israel surrounded with friends
i grew up in misgov
which is like a kibbutz like it's really
the best place to live
they have one of the best robotics team
in israel yes that's true
um so it was very dramatic i thought it
was the end of the world
for a teenager to say hey we're moving
to fort worth texas
i had no idea what this place was
and then indeed one thing led to another
and
i was bumped to class so i
went straight into my senior year um
and then started applying to colleges
because this is what you do in the us
right and i didn't really know english
at the beginning i didn't
want to speak with everyone because i
was angry right i was like yeah
um but then i didn't have a choice and i
the the first happy thing was that i
realized that i can get my license
driving's license before everyone else
so yes
it was the first good sign and then one
thing led to another and
um i got into texas christian university
which is a private university
um and it was i mean it was
such a different experience than all of
my other friends and um
i mean it was a great experience some of
my best friends for life
obviously were my roommates and yada
yada
um and then um
i i had a choice what what should i do
uh because my parents went back to
israel we were there on a relocation
so at the age of the 17 17 i did my
first
intuitive decision um
i didn't know that it's called intuition
back then
and it was to decide to stay by myself
in fort worth texas to complete my
degree
because all of my family went back to
israel and i'm glad i did that
um i i decided to also another intuitive
decision was
to come back to israel and still do my
military service even though i was 21
which is old
uh for military um here
and so you finished your degree in the
us and then you came and you
essentially volunteered or did your
military service back in israel did my
regular military service the only thing
was my mind was wired like you know when
you're about to graduate from college
they're like
you can do whatever you want and i
started sending my tv to places in the
military which no one does in israel
like
i found it and then um i
i ended up in the foreign affairs unit
uh
and then i decided that i want to be an
ambassador and like i want to connect
people to israel
and i want to do all these things and
all that jazz and so what was it about
the
experience in the foreign affairs unit
that made you say i want to be an
ambassador and i want to be a diplomat
for
now i think that it was something that
still
accompanies me until this very day and
that is that
it just feels like i'm a part of
something bigger
and i know i bet a lot of people say it
to you but
this is for me the most one of the most
um like the strongest motives for me to
do things
like i like to be a part of something
uh and over there it was kind of a daily
thing that you're doing
small stuff but you know the
repercussions of that
so it's very thrilling to me um
and then i i also recognize that it's a
passion of mine to connect people
to israel in kind of a ver not like a
non-cynical way
um because everyone around me was
cynical about it but
i i it's like something i recognized
there um so i think that
the obvious thing that people in the
foreign affairs unit do after they're
done and i moved
again to the netherlands to the hague
and i was assistant defense at the shed
there so
i did what i wanted to do
it was a great experience but it was too
cold
started probably to come back but and
honestly it was kind of
lonely too it's it's a very lonely um
it's lonely to be honest um
and i also realized that i don't want to
be an ambassador
no and i'm guessing it's not just the
location that is perhaps less lively
than
you know the city of tel aviv which is
one of the liveliest places in the world
but it's also
the fact that you are kind of alone
there right i mean you're leaving
straight after the army
a lot of people go to the go to
university together or move to
television together
and if you're going to a different place
yeah i completely understand
yeah and everyone at the embassy were
couples and
families and you know it's just kind of
like you kind of get the point of it
and i was already very independent so i
kind of
like experienced i traveled a lot
around europe like i lived in the states
so at the very
young age i was already kind of just
ticking the boxes on a lot of things
that i wanted to do
right so i moved back to israel
and i didn't know what i was going to do
so i signed up for a master's degree
right
of course um and then i started looking
for a job and it was kind of like a
culture shock you know it was
interesting because i was coming back to
my
own country but i was still experiencing
all the culture shocks that i've heard
that
like i felt like an hola almost
interesting
yeah wow even though you served in the
idf even though you grew up in the
kibbutz you felt
like an allah kind of yeah because you
kind of need to rebuild your life
yeah um and i had friends and i'm very
good at keeping touch with people but
there are a lot of struggles and you you
do have more
comfortable lives uh if you live in
europe or in the us
i'm sure you're aware um
and you kind of need to um give up all
the comfort things
that are very obvious when you live
abroad and not in israel
so it's even in the small things and in
your day-to-day stuff
and also i got back and i didn't know
what i was doing with my life and
you know like bam bam bam i'm doing this
i'm doing
that and you're like why everyone is
saying to me i'm overqualified for jobs
like
what what does it even mean like you
know you kind of
start realizing that you need to do some
work on yourself
and that was the point um so
talk to me a little bit about the the
transition from uh diplomacy and foreign
affairs
to israeli tech because that sounds like
a little odd transition
especially because it sounds like you
did there was a point where you did a
little a little bit abruptly
yeah well so when i got back i i started
working at the british council
um and i started as a project manager
and i moved up to be
the the head of the department and in
this organization
um they do collaborations with the uk on
various of
um sectors and one of the sectors is
research and science and innovation
and i think that was for me like the
ling ling ling
when i i realized that i'm
kind of a nerd like i'm wow
like it's science is amazing technology
is like
mind-blowing there are people who are
doing amazing stuff
and this whole idea of continuing to
promote israel through
tech kind of hit there so after three
years there i also managed
an innovation center and i wasn't there
for a very long time but i think there
it was the first time in my life that i
worked with entrepreneurs
and you speak to a lot of entrepreneurs
i'm
assuming so you know that that
sparking their eye and that passion it's
something that is completely like
it sucks you in like you you want to be
people
and you just there's no way back so from
working with
ministers and ceos and high levels which
was
i still do that it's great but
it didn't feel the same so i left
and like every good story
a friend of mine gave me a kick in the
butt to
come to one of the a delegation of
investors that wanted to be introduced
to some startups and it started from
there
um and it just kind of happened
naturally i know it's not a good recipe
or like something that people might be
able to follow
but for me the transition wasn't a one
day that i
decided that i'm going to do it it
wasn't a role
it was a very gradual
process and from
meeting all these delegations that come
to israel
and are craving meeting the best people
the best technologies want to hear more
about it
i also started doing um consulting to
uh innovation programs and accelerators
and hubs and all these angel investors
wanted me to work with them and then
it really led me to work with one
specific investor
that i'm working with also today
that is again doing something huge that
is much
bigger than me so the transition is
it was very gradual it wasn't
you mentioned you mentioned clearly and
you alluded a few times to this idea
that
helping israel through tech and
innovation
because you're coming from the foreign
affairs uh
segment and i'd love to to dive into
this a little bit because i think it's
it's really interesting
a lot of people are talking about israel
as a startup nation and you know
innovation through necessity
and no place for small dreams right and
i'm curious about the role on the
diplomatic side and the foreign affairs
side
on on israel being a startup nation so
what what what is the importance of that
and and give me a little bit of insight
into the back seat of
of of the of the diplomacy scene
well so i found afghanistan and
in um all sorts of angles so
i've also seen i've i first saw it from
the
defense angle okay
and there it's like it sounds weird but
it's very safe
israel it's kind of like the go-to place
for defense technologies solutions
everyone wants to work with israel even
if they're not admitting it
right okay and it was very interesting
to me because i saw how
people colleagues from all around the
world are craving so much to work with
israel but they're kind of
afraid to do so and i think
coming from the startups and
technologies
it's a much more legitimate
thing because people are just looking
for solutions for xyz
and you know that they find it here
and i think what's interesting for me
now and always was to be in this
intersection
of being the one who's either initiating
or supporting or accompanying the
collaborations and bringing in
government because you you need all of
you need everything so
the government role the private money
which is extremely important you can't
really do anything you can have
a lot of plans but you need the private
money
and all the other players so the private
sector the public sector some ngos even
and i think for me i was always in this
intersection
and when i decided to go ahead on my own
freelance way with israel tech venture
uh it was really from the purpose of
kind of um kind of like shining this
intersection and making it more
accessible to people
with the emphasis of bringing
investments to all these amazing
startups and for me that is the best
service that
i can do for my country to bring in that
foreign money
so is that really what the goal of ezra
tech is to
bring in uh partners across the seas
from different cultures and different
backgrounds to support
israeli tech and innovation yeah so you
know along the years i really
realized that i accumulated a network
of i'm truly i truly mean it
remarkable people from all around the
world
and in conversations we always had this
like okay so how do we begin
how do we start these collaborations how
do we i know this investor i know this
minister i know like
it was so like disorganized to me
and i knew that i could just if i have
my own platform i'm like
i don't owe anything to anyone really i
can just do
great connections that i want to do so
to be honest
it's just a platform for me to play
around
and do whatever i love which is to
connect all these
people who are very influential um from
all around the world
and in the process support startups that
i
truly admire and truly love and kind of
want an excuse to work with them to be
right
yeah that that that that sounds so so
cool so give me a little bit of
background about your experience right
now with this so what what part of this
really makes you you know really
passionate about this on the day-to-day
is it the meeting the startups is it the
meeting the people outside of israel and
connecting
seeing the connections unfold because
i'm guessing that a lot of the times the
connections
while they're being made through his
attack ventures they they expand
much further than that right as they go
on these longer-term
collaborations so which part of it
do you get really excited about so
pre-covered 19
we have two parts of the of that right
so
probably 19 i really enjoyed uh you know
i had these
marathon days of meeting 10 startups a
days and like
boom boom boom and sometimes it was very
boring and sometimes exciting
i met so many people it really like it's
it's a certain energy
that is can be really exhausting but can
really
nurture you as well yeah depends on who
you're meeting
um and i was working in a very very
quick
um pace nowadays
um and you know i had all these daily
incoming delegations and
come like we're here and come lecture
there it was a different vibe and i just
enjoyed the whole complex of that
nowadays i think what i enjoy most is
to really work uh with the companies
with the startups
um so i am on some boards and
working with portfolio companies of the
investor i'm working with
and it's really interesting to me to
really dive in
to the company and you know
half of the time i'm only listening
because i'm trying to understand
how i can help them and not to jump and
be like hey i connect you to this and
this
it's like something that you know in
israel we love to do
um to really soak in where they are what
they need
and try to help them again by connecting
them to both my network and
anything else that they need so i think
for me
it's really some what i enjoy most now
and it's also a time when you really
you're kind of deepening
every aspect of your life so i think for
me also at work and you're just
everything is more calm so i'm trying to
enjoy it because the craziness will
will return right we we know 100
20 minutes go by very very fast and i
think it's it's wonderful to hear about
somebody's journey
coming from outside of the tech world
and and finding passion within it and
finding
the right foothold and making a really
positive impact not just on on
entrepreneurs but also on the on the
state of israel as a whole
and so thank you for that but before we
leave i have to ask you for the most
important question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
well last week i learned a new word
from a friend that i think really
describes me and
probably people already saw it because
uh you read
people's energy you can't really define
them in words right
so the word was vivacious
okay i didn't know this word it's you
learn something new
and i think um the second word would be
a creator okay
and i think the last and most important
word would be
um heart wholehearted heart led
i think it's it's what's
what describes me the best i love it
thank you very very much best of luck
with ezra tech ventures and all the
wonderful work that you're doing
and i'm very excited to share this with
the world thank you thank you so much
for having me
bye